- [Voiceover] A particle
moves in the xy plane so that
at any time t is greater
than or equal to zero
its position vector is,
and they give us the
x component and the y component
of our position vectors, and
they're both functions of time.
What is the particle's acceleration
vector at time t equals three?
Alright, so or position, let's denote that
it's a vector valued function,
it's gonna be a function of time.
It is a vector.
And they already told
us that the x component
of our position is negative
three t to the third power
plus four t-squared, and the y component
is t to the third power plus two.
And so you give me any time greater than
or equal to zero, I put it in here
and I can give you the
corresponding x and y components.
And this is one form of notation
for a vector, another way of writing this,
you might be familiar
with engineering notation.
It might be written like, or sometimes
people write this as unit vector notation.
Negative three to the
third plus four t-squared
times the unit vector in
the horizontal direction,
plus t to the third plus
two, times the unit vector
in the vertical direction.
This is just denoting the same thing.
This is the x component,
this is the y component.
This is the component in
the horizontal direction,
this is the component in
the vertical direction,
or the y component.
Now the key realization is if you have
the position vector, well
the velocity vector's
just going to be the derivative of that.
So V of t is just going to
be equal to r prime of t,
which is going to be equal to,
well you just have to
take the corresponding
derivatives of each of the components.
So let's do that.
So if we wanna take the derivative
of the x component here
with respect to time,
we're just gonna use
the power rule a bunch.
So it's three times negative three,
so it's negative nine t-squared
and then plus two times four is eight,
so plus eight t to the first.
So plus eight t.
And then over here for the y component.
So the derivative of t to the third
with respect to t is three t-squared.
Three t-squared, and then the derivative
of two is just a zero, so I actually
have space to write that
three t-squared even bigger.
Three t-squared, alright.
And if we wanna find the
acceleration function,
or the vector valued function
that gives us acceleration
as a function of time,
well that's just going to be
the derivative of the velocity function
with respect to time.
So this is going to be equal to,
this is going to be equal to,
let me give myself some space.
And so the x component, well I just take
the derivative of the x component again,
and let me find a color
I haven't used yet,
I'll use this green, so let's see.
Two times negative nine, negative 18
times t to the first power plus eight,
derivative of eight t is just eight
if we're taking the derivative
with respect to t.
And then here in the orange, derivative of
three t-squared, so it's
two power rule here,
over and over again.
Two times three is six t to
the first power, just six t.
So this is, we've just been able
to by taking the derivative of
this position vector
valued function twice,
I'm able to find the
acceleration function.
And now I just have to
evaluate it at t equals three.
So our acceleration at t is equal to three
is equal to, so in green it's going to be
negative eighteen times three plus eight,
comma, and then we're gonna have
six times three, six times three.
And so what does this simplify to?
Well this is going to be equal to,
let's see, negative 18 times three is
negative 54, negative 54 plus eight
is negative 46.
Negative 46, and then six
times three is eighteen.
Did I do that arithmetic right?
So this is negative 54 plus eight.
So negative 54 plus four
would be negative 50,
plus another four would be negative 46.
Yep, there you have it.
Negative 46, comma eighteen.
That is its acceleration vector
at t is equal to three.